I wear big girl underwear like as in
like there's the underwear themselves
are a big girl they're they're big
they're they're they're Hefty they're
they're they're girthy they're like you
could use it as a parachute in an
emergency all the time yes pretty much
and I then I'll try to wear like a
hipster or like a skim which
occasionally I will wear and today I've
been picking out my underwear all day
from places I did not expect for them to
be in and I'm like this is where why I
wear my big girl underwear and when I
say big girl I'm picturing like
full-blown granny panty like the sides
are at least six inches long like you
put a baby in it and the baby could
swing it's a total baby diaper like
safety pin the side stitch cool I'm not
mad at that okay